يمكن قوله عن خسائر الجيش الاحتلال في
اليوم او في 100 يوم من
الحرب هي قد تكون غير مسبوقه في معارك
وحروب اسرائيل مع جيرانها العرب وتحديدا
مع فلسطينيين منذ تاسيس اسرائيل على انقاد
الشعب الفلسطيني في عام
48 في عام النكبه واضح بان الارقام هي
كبيره ومهه وغير يعني مقبوله على
الاستيعاب على الاقل من ج بالمجتمع
الاسرائيلي الذي لم يتوقع ان يتلقى مثل
هذه الضربه في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
وواضح بان المجتمع الاسرائيلي ما زال يعيش
هول هذه الصدمه حتى هذا اليوم حتى في
اليوم المئه من عمر هذه الحرب والعمليات
العسكريه المتواصله والمستمره في اكثر من
مكان في قطاع غزه ما زالت تؤدي الى قتلى
وجرحى في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي ايه قبل
قليل قامت وحده الانقاذ الجويه التابعه
لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي والمعروفه بوحده
رقم 669 بعمليه انقاذ واجلاء لجرحى
عسكريين من ارض المعركه تحديدا من المناطق
الشرقيه لمخيم البريج حيث نسلط الان عدسه
الكاميرا على هذا الدخان المتصاعد من هناك
وواضح بان هذه المروحيه نقلت جنودا من ارض
المعركه وعندما تتدخل هذه القوات لانقاذ
الجرحى عاده تكون اصابات الجنود او
العسكريين هي اصابات بليغه لذلك يتم
استدعاء وحده الانقاذ على عجل من اجل
انقاذهم واجلاهم على وجه السرعه من ارض
المعركه كما تسمع زين الان هذه المروحيه
العسكريه من فوقنا التي قامت باطلاق صاروخ
موجه
باتجاه المناطق اي الفلسطينيه سنرى اين
سيسقط هذا الصاروخ يبدو انه يستهدف
اي المخيمات الوسطى حيث نقف الان تحديدا
امام مخيم البريج حيث هذه الاعمده الدخان
المتصاعده من هناك اذا كنا نتحدث عن وحده
الانقاذ التي ما زالت تنقل جنودا
وعسكريين من ارض ال المعركه وعاده يتم
نقلهم على وجه السرعه الى المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه تحديدا الى مستشفى ف سوروكا
في بئر السبع عندما تكون الاصابات بليغه
للغايه الجيش الاسرائيلي كما هو معروف على
الاقل من خلال معطياته الرسميه هو يتحدث
عن
2500 جندي او
511 جنديا اصيبوا في المعارك منذ السابع
من اكتوبر لكن كما اشرت هذه الارقام تختلف
تماما حتى عن اق ارقام وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه التي تتحدث عن معالجه
3400 جندي اسرائيلي منذ بدايه الحرب وهي
تختلف تماما ايضا عن قوائم المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه التي تتحدث عن ارقام تزيد عن
5000 جندي وضابط اصيبوا في هذه المعارك
منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي وهذا ما
اكدته ايضا تحقيقات صحفيه لصحيفتي ارتس
الاسرائيليه وللصحه دعوت احرونوت اذا
المعارك هنا متواصله تحديدا هي تتركز الان
في المناطق الوسطى لقطاع غزه وكما نشاهد
ايه ال القصف المدفعي يعني هو مستمر وان
كان على نحو متقطع لكن ايضا الغارات
الجويه التي تستهدف مواقع بعينها في مخيم
البريج وفي المخيمات الوسطى احيانا من
خلال المروحيات العسكريه من نوع اباتشي
التي تكاد لا تغادر اجواء منطقه غلاف غزه
و